hello
and welcome to our career webinar
data scientist or data engineer mapping
educational and career opportunities
with ronald van loon the ceo of
intelligent world and an
advisory board member here at simply
learn
i'm stuart creek i'm a marketing manager
here at silverlearn
and
a few notes before we get started
on how to navigate the controls in webex
please enter your questions into the q a
box
and mark them for all panelists
we will collect those and present them
to
ronald during the q a session toward the
end of the webinar
if you use the chat function please
include host and presenter or all
panelists
so that we are able to
see your message
remember to hit send in both cases
so we're also going to be doing some
polls
during the webinar to ask your opinion
and the first one for practice is
what is your current job role
and also how are you feeling today
we've been asking this question ever
since the pandemic started
just to make sure that uh everyone
is doing well stuart you started with
the second question
i think i i get a pop-up what's your job
interest role data scientist or data
engineer
oh i am so sorry
you are correct um
let me
restart that
that's the worst thing that happens all
day we're good um
again i apologize this is the poll
prayer job role and how are you feeling
today
and later in the webinar we will be
asking a couple of times about
whether your preference for data
scientists or data engineering roles
has changed
give this another 15 seconds
all right
the results show that most of the people
today
here are students
and a large majority
feel either thumbs up or at least in the
middle
for those who mark thumbs down we hope
you will feel better by the end of the
presentation
because ronald is going to share with
you some valuable information and
ronald is the ceo of intelligent world
he's one of the foremost thought leaders
in data science and digital
transformation
we're very fortunate to have him on our
advisory board
at simply learned for data science
and he has been named by analytica as
world's number one influencer in data
and analytics
in automation and in the future the
economy in
tech so um i want to welcome
ronald and thank you
just consider being here again i can't
count anymore it's already for three
years i think we're doing this so
it's very nice
okay um so
just to take the temperature of the
audience we'll do
the second poll which is a similar
question to the one i mistakenly opened
before but
right off the bat we're asking
which you prefer a data scientist role
or data
engineer role
and as the answers come in i can see
that
data scientist is
the overwhelming preference
but we'll give it another
15 seconds
for those of you in the youtube live
audience you
are able to put your answers into the
chat
um and here's
the result
we did have a question from the audience
about what about data analysts but
that's a
subject for a different webinar although
ronald you're free to comment on that
but as you can see
data scientist is the overwhelming
preference so
over back to you yeah and i think it's
it's not
the biggest surprise and i got the
question quite often
um so what what's the difference between
the data scientist and the data engineer
um as and the reason why we don't have
data analysts in
right now is because the confusion is a
lot between a data scientist and a data
data engineer
and the good thing is they they
complement each other and they're
working together towards the same goal
in in different businesses and
they might have different
responsibilities and and different tasks
but ultimately they
solve the business problems and they
improve the business operations and
decision making and they both do this
so i think there's often some confusion
about the difference between these two
and the reason is because in many
business environments
data scientists are taking on numerous
other responsibilities and roles
due to the lack of available
talent stuart i think somebody is still
not on
mute that would be me
so if we look to the the difference
between generally speaking
data scientists they are more involved
on the side
of team management more involved in
communication
and organization and it works
specifically
with building machine learning models
and
if if you look to these
type of roles they heavily rely on
mathematics
such as statistical techniques to do
their their job so if you're interested
in this type of career which
and most of the people are you will be
using
research to solve your business problems
and you will use analytical
um and machine learning and statistical
type of methods for
prescriptive and for predictive modeling
what we see with data scientists they
also look for trends and opportunities
in data
and they use algorithms that help to
build programs that improve the
automation
but also make recommendations to the
business leaders that will
improve the processes and that will
enhance the different type of strategies
so if we look to data engineers on the
other hand
they support data scientists within the
organization and helping them to reach
the conclusions that they need
to to support the decision making by
working heavily with the data like
you can think about data man database
management or data integration
but also modeling or cell service and
and data pipelines
so think of data engineers as
more a supportive role within the
organization so helping to improve the
efficiency of the organization
with them from a larger perspective and
it's a very software and program
oriented position within the company so
if you're interested in this
career um you'll need to be making sure
that
your data storage and your collection
systems
they are current that's what you focus
at and they are
acceptable but also you work on
developing
custom software for example or merging
systems together
other things you you work about is
storing and securing data
and system and integration management
and you also start by finding out
how to improve the data quality this is
a very important
role because the data quality is crucial
in getting the results
so specific responsibilities for data
scientists and data
engineers they often change depending on
the industry or the business or
even on the manager um because it's
always
up to the business leaders to make those
respective responsibilities of the data
scientists and the data engineers
clear within the organization and it's
really depending on
who is good at what there's no
one-size-fits-all
if i would like to to compare it
a game of chess it's it's very um
popular i think right now
um due to the the netflix serie
um if you look to a game of chess your
goal is to capture the opponent's pieces
uh which represents the different
challenges in that the organizations
face
in their environment and businesses they
need to create
all kinds of strategies look just like
in a chess game
and then they move their pieces around
the board in order to overcome all these
these type of challenges so
if we look to data scientists and data
engineers they are like your your
knights your bishops your your rooks
and more important pieces in in the game
of chess and if they can work together
and move accordingly they can overcome
basically any type of challenge
and and eventually win the game and then
create a new solution for a company that
helps them to to succeed
so i think that's a high level overview
i'm stewards of the difference between
data scientists and data engineer
and also the reason why we don't have a
data analyst included
right now and
so for the two roles data scientist and
data engineer
what specific skill sets do each of
these jobs require
so that people can match that to their
own
personal aptitudes and skills yeah i
think it's good to dive a little bit
deeper into it
and maybe very nice story to share i
recently spoke to a data scientist of
one of
one of the world's leading technology
companies
and he worked on some significant data
scientist projects for
some household company names including a
favorite major
baseball league organization i i can
unfortunately not share all the names as
it is confidential chat
but when i asked him to describe his job
he said that he helps businesses and
governments do
more with analytics and ai and whether
it's deep learning whether it's machine
learning whether they analyze
text or audio or video or whatever else
they analyze
it that doesn't matter so much and what
he also mentioned is that he focuses on
helping organizations to take control
of their data journey so they can
overcome
their business challenges and use ai and
use data and use analytics to their
advantage
so i think it's a really important
statement because
ai is becoming synonymous with
organization success every company is a
data company every company is an ai
company
and they become synonym not only with
success but with innovation
with differentiation because all
differentiations
are based upon data all innovations
are based upon data but companies they
can't achieve any of these ai driven
outcomes without the skills from
industry specialists like data
scientists and data engineers so
that's why these two roles are so very
important and why we
discuss them today so if we look to
today's data scientists
they have to understand machine learning
technologies and techniques
you can think about clustering natural
language programming
and deep learning but also
programming languages and then you can
think about python sql
or scala or r um but also java is
is important and you have to learn about
big data platforms big data platforms
like
cloudera or mongodb and and also oracle
and i think it's important to have an
understanding of data visualizations and
then you can think about
tools like tableau or like sus
what does is is important is the
communication and the storytelling they
are key for data scientists because
they not only have to be able to
organize different teams
they're also responsible for successful
algorithms and business outcomes
so they have also to be able to
relate concepts to people in different
roles and in different departments
in a business and what that means
that they have to be a strong they have
to have
a strong understanding of the business
itself
and how algorithms are going to impact
the success of the organizations in all
the different type of
capacities which means that analytical
skills are
are must because using analytics
is just part part of the job then if we
look to data visualization and reporting
or risk analysis data mining cleansing
you can also think about research and
understanding the big data platforms
understanding the cloud tools
understanding your data warehousing and
the the data structures that you have
these are skills that you need as a data
scientist as well
um from from a higher level perspective
in order to
to be and to stay competitive but you
also need to consider a specialization
and then you can think about choosing a
particular industry
so if you're in a certain industry like
in finance or you are
in healthcare which are both rapidly
evolving
industries there as well you have to dig
deeper into
into the complexities of ai within this
industry and
the complexities of machine learning and
database management
specifically in this industries so
specializations like these are very
helpful
for your own understanding what you like
to do uh because data science is is a
broad field and it can be really
overwhelming to people
um we are looking to pursue the career
in this
is this path
if we then look to the data engineers
they are much more
software focused and and i explained
this already
in the previous part but if we look to
managing and maintaining data pipelines
this is a regular part of the position
and so putting your your data into
models
data warehousing and into the data
architectures
so they are in in charge of building
and maintaining data storage systems
which involve using software
that stores all the data to give an
example
you might be in charge of how to
integrate new data from
new client databases but also at the
same time
the security it's always going to be
a very important part of your job so all
your data needs to be processed
and need to be secured another part of
the job
and and the skills that you require
other programming languages
um understanding technologies such as
sql but also nosql or hadoop or java or
python
there are regular skill sets which are
necessary to to succeed as a data
engineer
if you're developing your skills in sql
this is going to be a great place to
start
as a data engineer because it's it's the
foundation programming language
that that they use so if you're thinking
about starting and i saw
quite some students this is something
where you can start off
and the challenge is that as their job
is heavily software and programming
focused
these technologies often they change
over time and change
quite rapidly so the part of the job is
understanding how to adapt
and how to react to to using these
technologies and education is key in
this
so a lot has to do with your
your with organizing the data but it's
also
more a collaborative effort data science
is a collaborative effort anyhow
so as a data engineer you will need to
spend
a lot of time listening to other data
science professionals and to to learn
from them
so how do you know what what position is
best suited for you so if we look to
data science
i think it's great for people who are
some kind of natural leaders team
leaders
so if you're a natural leader then it's
a good indication
that data science is much more up your
alley and i know
most of the audience likes to become a
data scientist
but i think you need to and especially
if you start
look at what fits best for you so it can
be maybe a second step
or a third step but have in mind what
fits
with you before becoming blind for the
title only
um what i see as well with with data
science
they're going to be heavily involved in
building machine learning models so
that's a
capacity that you need to have as well
if you look to the data
engineers they're all about being data
experts
and about being software experts so
if you're more technological savvy
and if you're a great programmer and if
you could see yourself
more behind the scenes assisting the
organization using their data
then i think this is definitely more
suited for you but
once again if you are more this
technical guy
it can be a route for you a step up to
in the future move more
to managerial tasks and more growth
towards
a data scientist so if you have
data scientists in your mind just also
don't forget to look at a data engineer
so i think this is um
stuart this covers most of the important
skills
for both the data scientist and and the
data engineer
and that that's excellent because we did
have some questions coming through the
chat about
um you know the possible career path
from one to the other
and uh you spoke about that so what
industry
trends today are emerging that that
impact the demand for each of these job
roles
and how the job roles uh themselves are
being shaped
yeah what we mentioned already um
the whole spectrum is changing and it's
really changing rapidly
so it's important to keep an eye on all
the trends and
what new technologies are pop-up and
because if we look to the world today
this is let's say
how you keep yourself up to date and to
find out
what is your route for your future job
position
and even further increased value for
data scientists data engineers
that bring to an organization if you
understand the trends better
this is going to help help you out so
this trend is also going to help you
understand
the technologies that are emerging today
and
where you should focus at least some
some high level in
education for yourself i think one of
the main
trends right now it's it's automation so
it's used in in a variety of capacities
across industries
and if i talk about automation i
talk about robot process automation and
this has been
seen a widespread adoption during the
urgent new initiatives
in advancing this digital transformation
and especially during this pandemic is
really
exploding in in demand as the roi cases
are are trivial and as well as more and
more workers they shift to
to remote work scenarios so rpa makes
things
a lot easier for companies who need to
update legacy type of systems and
perform all kind of repetitive manual
tasks that help
employees adjust new technologies in
changing the work and environments like
i'm using new crm or using hr systems or
finance systems
and within these they can use the
machine learning applications and
and the software robotics another trend
i think
to keep in mind is the natural language
processing
and this improves processing
capabilities of data set
and results in improving the operational
efficiency
but also the decision decision-making
capabilities of organization across the
different industries
so common uses of of nlp in the business
contexts that we see
every day are for example chatbots and
a more advanced type of chatbot is
conversational ai
or voice recognition the most one of the
most known
is for example apple siri or amazon
alexa
and nlp performs tasks such as one
sentiment analysis um but also
name entity recognition or
co-friends co-reference resolution
and also speech tagging is one of the
items
so if we look at popular programming
languages
then we have to think about python and
python have
specific tools for utilizing and
building natural language
processing programs so this is why
conversational analytics dies directly
into the nlp
and that's very important and this is
because
this process is about extracting data
from speech patterns
just like our voice assistants examples
as i just
just mentioned so businesses tailor
marketing campaigns that improve
the customer experience because they're
able to understand
the context from the conversation in
calls or
in question and interactions which
programs use
where they use speech and it can be
either a chat
or it can be analysis from from your
your call teams your sales teams and if
we look at this point
i'm i'm sure that you have at least
heard of the term
deep learning by now and natural
language processes using
deep learning models that classify and
label text and voice data
which help them to bring the meaning but
also improve the accuracy of the data
and
now we are over 95 accuracy of voice
recognition
which is the human level of recognition
as well
then we have if we look to the trends ai
ai is a continuous trend that's
relevant moving into the future for for
the coming years
because businesses they need to to speed
up the transformation
but also cater huge churches in
in e-commerce especially now during this
pandemic and then
over here shops are closed i think in
many parts of europe shops are closed
um i think also some parts of the u.s so
e-commerce is really
taking off um and it's changing customer
behavior
um it's changing the habits and the
expectations
and yeah to survive amidst this
disruption and this uncertainty this is
this
is crucial a crucial trend to follow
and they can't do this
they can't use ai without data
scientists and without the data
engineers
but i'd like to specifically discuss the
ai and the
intelligent applications which we just
briefly when we mentioned the chatbots
or when we
mentioned the personalized marketing so
we literally see
countless of examples of intelligent
applications
being used across the industry right now
whether it's
in banking and finance intelligence
application
help with with combating fraud and with
enhancing the the security but also
for example in healthcare ai
applications that are being used to
detect cancer and all different kinds of
diseases
in patient diagnostics or in in drug
discovery
if we look to ai applications that are
being used to improve
supply chains and logistical operations
and if you're interested in that
i did a webcast about this um
two weeks ago so you can google that and
ai and logistics and and can
dive further into that part or improving
industry and factor factory 4.0 type of
innovation with smart robotics and also
with
improved routine routine deliveries type
of
ai applications one other one um
industry i would like to to mention
where ai is used is
agriculture maybe it's not the most
obvious one but
ai is improving farming efficiency and
the farming
outputs by predicting planting and
harvesting time for example but also
a lot with iot type of connected devices
and improving the efficiency in farming
substantially
one hot topic since the pandemic and you
can imagine why everybody's working from
home
is security it's very important so
especially
as these remote work scenarios have
emerged
as part of this new workforce and
customers
and organization data
they always need to to be processed
securely and data scientists
data science security professionals they
need to understand
all the latest technologies and the
tools that are used for
for big data analysis and for security
of your data so these are yeah just only
some of the emerging trends of course
there are there are more
which are impacting the future of of
data science and data engineer workforce
so keep an eye on this as these new
trends emerge and evolve over time
and your education will prepare you to
work in a world shaped by these type of
trends
and help you to work with these type of
technologies as well if you
keep an eye on it so i think it's uh
yeah the most
the most emerging trends currently today
i think we have a goal now yeah and i'm
going to uh go ahead and launch that
this is just to get a kind of feel for
the background of the
folks in the audience and
their your educational background
in a world where
[Music]
for example about a year ago
in the united states the president
issued an executive order that said
that government jobs
would look primarily at skills rather
than education
so skills are are becoming a very
important part of the
hiring mix as compared to the
qualifications from education
[Music]
and
see that most folks in the audience here
have
a bachelor's or master's degree
which is a great foundation
okay
so when we look at that
what type of education is required for
data scientists and data engineers
and and if somebody's
in the process what path should they
plan out
for their education towards each field
i think it's good to see that most
people in the audience have already a
bachelor degree or even higher
and if you look to data scientists they
need an
undergraduate degree in data science or
similar fields
and for an entry level position as a
data scientist but a bachelor degree
will
only get you so far in the industry as
as a data scientist and so i strongly
recommend to pursuing
a master's degree so you can get a
strong education in the fields such as
for example ethics or your data privacy
or visualization
or marketing analytics
if let's say with getting a phd later
this will open up all kind of your your
abilities to get
different positions and even more
advanced careers
as a data scientist also if we look to
certifications there are
available and they're really important
for data scientists as
a stamp of proof next to the
practical experience if we look to the
to the certifications they will help you
to narrow down your focus
and your interest and also help you to
align
with your specialization so as we have
mentioned before when we were talking
about the skill requirements of the data
scientists
those popular certifications include for
example
certified analytics professionals or
cloudera's certified associates which
are important ones
and of course organization and
organizations like simpler they're very
happy to help you with your education
and your certification
to be sure to find out
how we simply learn you can can help you
you can can further
talk to to the people after the the
webcast
if we look to the salaries and that's
probably what triggers many many people
so data science sellers they're very
competitive and even on average
it's 120 000 a year um
and can even yeah grow up to 200 000 a
year
depending on the area depending on the
industry
and but also depending on the company
you work for
and how advanced you are in in your
career path
so it's important to start
pursuing your education now because it
could take
let's say about four five six years to
get a
bachelor degree depending um if you do
it full time or you do it next to
your job um and at least more than one
year
to get a master's degree and then yeah
you can do all different kind of
additional certifications but
with um data scientist being such
an important and growing field right now
it's worth
it's worth it i think and it it will set
you up
for an even more bright future for
success
in in this emerging field so
as for data engineers
i forgot to move the slides and as for
the data engineers
um they need an undergraduate degree
in in science in math and in in business
such as a bachelor's degree in computer
science and in physics and statistics or
in computer engineering for example
but if you look to the degree and
degrees is not everything you need to
get
out there in the world and gain some
experience
like getting an internship or building
your own portfolio of
projects that you are working on to gain
the attention of the organization and to
get
a real job into the field because the
real job really gives you the experience
and the recognition to move on and to do
to educate faster and learn from from
others as well
other courses you can can think on other
courses on algorithms or encoding or
a database management they're also going
to help you out if you want to
to progress in this career um
i mentioned already before sql sql is
really important for data engineers
and it's also used to query your data
and for for the sql systems so
since statistical analysis is also part
of the job
i think you can think about python and r
they are currently
the most popular programming language to
familiar familiarize
yourself with and maybe last but not
least
certifications are also available for
data engineers to put you on top
on top of your career so there are many
certifications available
for you to pursue such a becoming a
certified data
management professional or
a cloudera certified professional and
and with data engineering being
an emerging field and showing no signs
of
slowing down there are always
higher educational paths to consider
such as a master degree in computer
science or
or in computer engineering and
as we finish talking about the education
requirements i think
what's important to keep keep in mind is
that data science
and data engineering there this is a
constantly and it's a rapidly evolving
field
so what we tell today will be different
in six months time and
difference in in half a year so
different in in one year
so keep an eye on it so it's your best
interest to keep studying
in your own time and and keep yourself
current with the new developments in
this field
so that you can bring the most value
to the organization to the industry but
as well growing within an existing
company over time for for yourself
so yeah this is the high level
educational background and requirements
for
for both different roles ronald would
you go back
a couple of slides just to the data
scientists slide um
so that people can see that and um
in our recording but um yeah and and
so the two paths um
are slightly i mean not slightly
different two paths are different
but that as you can see
there's a way into the data scientist
path from the data engineering uh
educational base um
what kinds of careers are available
uh once people are qualified as data
scientists and data or data engineers
yeah i think this is an important topic
especially if we look to
the let's say the wish to become a data
scientist much more than a data engineer
and why this data engineer role
is also to keep an eye on or keep as an
option
in your career path and
i wanted to break up i think in in two
type of of careers maybe
some regular most obvious type of career
and more exceptional type of career
options but let's
let's start with the normal regular type
of career
and these are more common and these are
more generally require
less experience than the exceptional
type of careers and which we
discuss discuss after this one so you
can become
let's say a data analyst who is
responsible for optimizing
of data where where you can clean where
you can extract where you can analyze
data where you can query databases or
where you can mine data and often
looking for patterns in data to help you
to support
decision makers but you can also
become if we look to the career options
and move more into an application
architect
an application architect who handles of
all the the software application design
and development
so you need to know about application
development development in that case
and then you can think about testing or
updating applications and integrating
applications
but this is a career option
for for the route that you can take
another career option
is for example moving more into
a business analyst type of role who uses
data
to target the specific needs of the
business and communicate necessary
changes that are going to help a
business to succeed depending on the
goals of the management and
and the sea level and the stakeholders
it's a type of role which which can be
very helpful within this this domain and
there are also
career options as statistician
who models the business models and help
to determine the meaning behind
the data and relay in a way that that
makes sense
of the business decision makers while
supporting the strategies of of your
organizations
and these are just four types of
let's say different routes who you can
which you can take
and these are more the the normal career
options
for data scientists but many choose from
um yeah you can also choose from from
different ones like the database
administrator or machine learning
engineer
or a business intelligence development
developer
and and many more then
you can also look from from a different
perspective and
this is more the exceptional type of
career choices that you can have
so these are typically more advanced
career options
and they're generally more designed for
people who have spent
years of advancing their careers not
only in the data science but also
within the organization within different
industries
understanding the business but they are
i think very rewarding if you are just
starting out in your
beginning stages of your career you can
think about
yeah different um exceptional data
science
careers so you can aim for advanced
within your organization and
envision yourself a future and and grow
as a data scientist and
first for example data scientists who
become a consultant
so big companies will hire you to work
on major problems and strategies within
the company
and in this case you often get work on
a diverse range of projects or cases
with lots of room for for high level
promotions and company partnership but
you use your data science skill
in a consultative role on what we also
see
as more exceptional type of
of career path are for example product
development
this career option that's for more
software machine learning
oriented people and i think great for
for engineers so it's fulfilling career
paths because of you
you get to heavily influence
how the products are built within the
company and
one specific thing about this is if you
look
the people who are really going to
decide how the future of companies look
like
are the ones who create the new type of
disruptive products and disrupt the
services within an organization
and this these are the most valuable
people
in the future if you understand the
market if you understand
the product and the service needs and
you have
the data science skills you basically
you can you build your your own
business and your own services but these
are the people who are
one of the most valuable people in the
future
in the domain of data science you can
also think about
sales specialists so work on different
type of products and
in cases but more from an
entrepreneurial mindset
and where you start educating and
acting and adding sales skills to to
your portfolio
and i think in this range as well you
can think about business development
roles
um so where you can work in areas of
marketing or in finance and heavily
influence the business operation
to get work a lot of um yeah on the
different data sets to create
all different kind of new developments
and
new markets so if we look to this this
exceptional career choices
i think they have a lot of
responsibilities and they have a lot of
value um and if you look to
responsibilities you can think about
establishing
a data driven culture i think it's going
beyond
just being the data scientist or you can
think about
leading full data projects or building
product knowledge
um improving the communication skills
within an organization but also
using the business knowledge to create
new products new services
to develop your culture so if you decide
to work the path of an engineer
and you also have other career options
you can can think about let's see
career options like being an hadoop
developer or being a bi developer
or being a technical architect
other roles can be etl developer
but also data warehouse engineer
or a quantitative data engineer so
there's
different more technical type of roles
and your role might
also include being some kind of data
platform engineer or data infrastructure
engineer or
a data warehousing engineer
and and maybe grow to achieve data
officer
and this this role is some that is
growing step by step within more and
more organizations
as data becomes much more important
within the strategy within the
innovation strategy from organizations
and within the day-to-day strategy
basically as well
so there's a lot of different options
and career paths to take
and which one is the best part
for you yeah that's something that you
have to decide yourself
what does fits well with you what do you
like
but i think what's important drive your
own career
and make think from what what you like
think from what you're good at and tell
these type of requirements and and
requests
to your organization so they can search
for
the next opportunity that fits you well
and builds your own path towards your
goal that you have in mind
i think that's yeah working best and
there's no black and white
or predefined best path
at all define it yourself but be
proactive
and let people know what you want let
people know what you're good at
and this way i think you can develop
your career best
so this is yeah the broad range
of different kind of career options
stuart
great so now that we've
heard from you ronald i'd like to ask
the audience
if they've changed their opinion on
which role
appeals most now i'm curious
and we'll just keep this open for
another 30 seconds
and about 15 seconds more
it's still overwhelmingly data
scientists but i think
a few more people have indicated
data engineering as a preference
data scientist as a preference yeah most
of most
are still with data scientists but i
think a the response for data engineers
a little bit higher than it was earlier
it's good it's it's a process and it's
as mentioned define your your own career
and look
from what you're you're best at and this
way you can
guide it best i think
so the top industries and domains
[Music]
where are the best places for people to
look
for opportunities to practice as data
scientists and data engineers
yeah i think there's a number of obvious
sectors
which which we all know um i covered
already some general ai applications
across the different industries
um earlier to demonstrate some of the
industry
trends that are impacting the popularity
of these type of roles
but if we look to for example huge
companies who have made
name themselves partly due to the
contribution of data science and data
engineering professionals
they yeah everybody knows them the the
big tech companies
and they have massive teams of
practitioners
in each of the roles that comprise
large teams of diverse high-level data
specialists
you can for example think about facebook
and they have
373 data engineers and seven
more than 700 data scientists or if you
think about
ibm they have around 650
data scientists and around 160 data
engineers
tech companies like google around 550
data scientists and 180 data engineers
apple 200 data scientists and 100 plus
data engineers
or oracle also 120 plus data scientists
and around 70 data engineers
so this gives a good idea from these
huge tech companies
what the sizes of of their data
scientists
and data engineers grew so
there are a lot of let's say
exceptional examples because not
everyone is looking into pursuing these
these two careers um and they're not
going to to end up work for the apples
or the googles
maybe many people would would like to
but as you can see
it is still a limited number from the
the total amount of jobs that there are
but pretty much every industry and every
domain
and company both big or small they are
looking for
for data science and data engineering
professionals and i think that's
that's the good thing so if we then look
to industries
for example the supply chain
organizations need data scientists to
help them solve all different
difficult type of challenges like
reducing the environmental
impact of global sourcing or enabling
them to meet the new customer demands
with mass personalization but also
having getting insights
in the changes in the supply chain
almost at real time especially during
this this type of
pandemic and they both need data
engineers and data scientists
to help them advance goals for
for demand forecasting for accelerate
accelerate
what they call cognitive procurement or
also improve the end to end-to-end
visibility
um sometimes through through blockchain
which is another technology
um by the way which we we're not gonna
discuss today
then we have the technology
organizations
they need data engineers to help them to
expand the software development
objectives
like building new algorithm algorithms
for the recommendation or for the search
or for the personalization systems
where we see that data engineers they
needed to act as a part of the teams
that develop and productize
the key data sets but also to build
machine learning models
for for the marketing teams for example
another industry
and you can think about this is telecom
so organizations need data scientists
and data engineers
to help increase network security
but also you can think about mitigating
fraud or
leverage ai for better customer
experiences better customer experiences
is everywhere some of other top
industries
hiring data engineers right now are
e-commerce
which you are probably not surprised
about e-commerce is really taking off
um especially as the brick and mortar
are struggling due to this pandemic but
also
industries like finance like within
finance insurance
companies or within the health care
industry
also in consulting and as
mentioned already this enterprise type
of software
so for data scientists some of the top
industries to look
in is finance
scientific and technology type of
services
manufacturing and banking
pharmaceuticals
industrial so you see that there's quite
some
industries really advancing
in data in analytics in ai and where
the need for data scientists is really
taking off
and which is good if you you move your
career in in this direction so the
options are
very broad and your options are also of
course you can move from one industry to
the other and use the experience
that you have in one industry for the
other and for the other new company you
you start working
so i've seen in my experience a lot of
data scientists and data engineers to
focus
solely on on this high technology
companies that everybody
knows but yeah i think
it's a nice idea to work for these
big tech companies but it's very hard to
get employed
and there's so many different other
opportunities
who are yeah industries and companies
are really
needs in the need for for good data
scientists for good data engineers where
you can flourish yourself and can
develop yourself
and then yeah you can look more at niche
sectors and sub sectors
that are worth checking out and in the
end you need to feel
to to find a company where you feel
comfortable and the good thing i think
about
what's happening now um work from home
becoming
more a standard type of work
for many of the companies the good thing
about this
is that you can work from anywhere so it
doesn't matter
whether you're living in a small town
whether you live in
in in the east in the west in the north
or in the south
of the world you can work from anywhere
the bad thing of course of this
is it's harder to get together
but anyhow what i see is that many
data data science teams they work any
anyhow distributed
over the globe and come together now and
then to to share their experience
um one one industry i would like to to
mention is the pharmaceutical
industry um where you have the drug
manufacturing the
genomics and the veterinary life
sciences
and also of course and now the vaccine
the vaccine requirements the vaccine
distribution requirements where we see
quite some some troubles
all over the world
then if we look to the the industrial
industry um
where you can look at specific sub
sectors
and then you can think about
construction or metal fabrication
or industrial components where you can
work in r
d and supporter r d
with data and analytics
either as a part of their servers
so what you see a lot if is that let's
say
product companies become data companies
so they start providing insights about
their products and this insights become
a new type of services
but also of course um in the product
optimization
or predicting their maintenance
for these these products which are areas
where
the the amount of good people are really
required
one sector which i mentioned before the
agricultural sector
you can think about farming you can
think about
fishery so here you could be working on
projects like autonomous
tractor development or automated
irrigation
or digitized crop disease detection
so there's many different areas where
data analytics can help
to improve agriculture in
different ways and have a more
sustainable type of agriculture
so it's important i think to keep an
open mind
not get stuck on one perspective on one
title
um and which can in the end narrow down
your career path
be open-minded be open for different
roles
be open to make different steps if you
go ahead
and maybe smaller steps would bring
in the end a bigger step than just
aiming for this
data scientist title so
no matter i think what your passion
where your interest lies
you can find an industry you can find a
sector
and you can find a company that fulfills
your needs and your dream job
and your dream career path and
if you start something it's not let's
say the end
it's a next step in your career so make
steps
maybe fast steps and educate yourself to
stay up to date
and i think that's a nice
moment to move to the q a yeah
um we've got many more questions than we
can
answer in the time available but i want
to start with this one because it
touches on two things um from amandeep
who says i'm pursuing a data scientist
program from simply learn
i'm presently working as an investment
banker
and can you suggest a good path for my
career
the reason i chose this one is because
there's a number of people
who are in finance or
in commerce or in chemical
engineering or mechanical engineering
who are all
curious about whether and how to move
into the data scientists role and here's
somebody who's
who's making that transition through the
simply learn data scientist program
so what advice could you give to amanda
and the other folks here
so finance is one of the leading
industries i think that's
that's the great part and whether you
are in fraud detection
or defining models to to predict
investments um which which is very
let's say um job in demand
but there you need really need a lot of
domain knowledge so the good thing is if
you have certain domain knowledge for
example in
in investments and then
advancing your career by doing a data
science
data scientist course um or a bachelor's
or
a phd this is really where you can add
value to your your job so you have
basically two
routes you you start as a data engineer
you you start
as a junior data scientist um
or you have a certain expertise already
and then you advance
your career and the people with the
combination
within a certain industry so
industry expertise i was talking about
these specific rules which are
exceptional
whether it's in product development
whether it's in in sales or in
consulting
these are the roles which are very
valuable if you have
the best of both worlds both from
data science as from from the industry
then you can go for this exceptional
career so
advice is yes go ahead develop yourself
much more in the in the direction of
analytics
and data science and
make it known within your organization
that you can help them properly with
um let's say job openings
which i didn't expect for example for
product development if you can
develop new financial products
yeah you you're more worth than your
body in gold
um as as they say an expression it's
this expression but
i don't know if it's an english
expression but that's that's
the opportunities that you have so
everybody who has no
let's say analytical experience extend
your career
with data with analytics with with
the data science data scientist
possibilities from simply learn because
that's
what brings real value exceptional value
compared to
the normal jobs thank you
um i'm going to mention a question from
akash
but i'm going to move to another
question right after akash asks if it's
too late to learn these things at the
age of 25.
i'm going to switch to the other
question
which is um from
learner i don't have his name but he has
a bachelor's degree in math
29 years experience in management and
sales
in the financial and insurance sector
uh in his management role he developed
and led a data governance team
um i should say i don't know if it's a
he or she so
but what is a good path for this
person to get back into data science
after having led a team of 18
in his management career um
it's not clear for me if they have
already
experience in either data science or
analytics or
or data engineering or not but
let's assume they have not they have let
the data
governance team already so they know how
to manage these
these type of teams so i think
on one hand is yeah educate yourself
as a data scientist start
with the simple simple side
but i think what can help you
a lot is further become
and advance your career from um leading
the
data governance team to leading the
total
data science team to leading a product
development team
and maybe even have a career moved to a
chief
chief data officer so leading
core transportation from a data
perspective
where you combine your knowledge from
both the industry
as your knowledge from from data science
and that's
yeah still unique in in every
i think in every industry and most
valuable
i think if you yeah moving into this
this product development
direction or service development
direction and where you
combine the both the knowledge of data
science and
the industry knowledge and your career
knowledge of 20
29 years um i think it was finance
that's where the real real value is
it's definitely not too late to start
whether you are
25 whether you are 50 or maybe even when
when you are 70
i don't think it's ever too late because
you need to stay up to date
anyhow in your career path if you like
working
and you like working at your 70th it's
still
worth investing time in it because
that's what is required right now if you
want
your job well um
well do you have time for a couple more
questions
um let me check five minutes more
okay um i'm going to ask
one is uh does the ai
engineer support the data scientist or
does the data scientists support the ai
engineer
um so if if you look to the
the data engineer supports the data
scientist
the ai engineer it's let's say combined
role where you take care for the data
collection
for the modeling which is also part of
the data scientist
so it's overlapping but
let's say the the ai engineer
supports the data scientists if you ask
the
question black and white okay
um edward asks if it's possible for
someone with a lack of computer
programming background to take up a
career in data science or data
engineering
yeah i think definitely and
i would even say if you're interested in
data science
and you have no background but you have
the will to learn
um and then you definitely can can
become a data scientist or can become a
data engineer um
i think these these career plots have a
lot of diverse options and
definitely different specializations
where you can move ahead
so i think it's more the drive
and the will to succeed then it's let's
say
where you say okay you can't or you
can't do it based upon your previous
education
um and and from there discussed a couple
of times
today you need to find your path so if
there's certain
activities where you're not not good at
if
if you don't like or you're not good at
programming
um try to avoid that part
within the role and if you look to to
larger organizations
they need so many different roles so you
need to find a role that fits
fits with your capabilities fits with
your interest and fits with your skills
but yet don't let let's say your
background
financial background whether you have
the the means or not
um or let's say educational background
don't let that stop you going into a
direction i think it's much more
important
to have the drive and the will to learn
and the possibilities
are there to educate yourself
either with with courses available on
the internet
with elearn and so there's multiple
different ways to to educate yourself
so it's more the spirit and the drive
than it is the
the previous education that gonna make
you successful or not
okay great i think unfortunately that's
all the time we have
for questions um
and i apologize to people who have
submitted questions that we couldn't get
to
but i want to go ahead and thank um
ronald for this
wonderful uh presentation today i think
it's been
i hope that our audience has found it
extremely helpful
um i also want to mention um a new
program
from skill up from simply learning
called skill up
which is a way to sample our
courses through the on-demand video
content
over 300 skills over a thousand hours of
video
content all free and
i think i have included the link in our
chat window a couple of times
i will do that one more time before we
go and
um that's a good way to look at what we
have to offer before committing to
our more involved programs so
again thank you to ronald and
thank you all for being here we invite
you
to be part of our community through our
social media channels
on linkedin twitter
and facebook and
we also hope that you will join us for
future simply learn webinars
and with that uh that concludes our
webinar today
and we all thank you for being here
and it's time to log off of webex
and until next time
thank you
you